los países de la Unión Europea están
viendo un aumento de la presión
migratoria en los últimos meses en sus
fronteras Exteriores en 2022 se
produjeron más de 330.000 entradas
irregulares a través de las fronteras
exteriores una cifra no vista desde 2016
cuando se produjo una crisis migratoria
sin precedentes la mayoría de personas
entraron a través de los balcanes
occidentales pero también a través de la
ruta del este del Mediterráneo
básicamente a través de Grecia y Turquía
la gran mayoría de personas provenían de
Siria de Afganistán y de son como
comentábamos cifras que no se veían
desde la crisis migratoria de 2015-2016
cuando entraron más de un millón de
personas dentro de la Unión Europea en
gran parte debido a la política de
puertas abiertas defendida por la
excanciera alemana Angela Merkel pero
que provocó una gran descoordinación y
también una confianza que se quedó muy
deteriorada entre los países de La Unión
europea la comisión europea presentó
hace ya dos años una reforma migratoria
pero apenas ha habido avances
precisamente por ello y debido a estas
cifras de los últimos meses los líderes
europeos se reúnen de forma
extraordinaria en una Cumbre a
principios de febrero para abordar la
cuestión migratoria